THEY SAID IT IS OUT OF HAND.
>> Dana: GLAD YOU’RE THERE FOR
US.
LET’S BRING IN FORMER DHS
ACTING SECRETARY CHAD WOLF.
CUSTOMS AND BORDER PATROL HAD
763 UNACCOMPANIED MIGRANT
CHILDREN IN ITS CUSTODY AS OF
TUESDAY.
625 OF WHOM HAD BEEN HELD MORE
THAN 72 HOURS.
THAT WILL BE ANOTHER ISSUE,
RIGHT?
THE ISSUE OF HOW LONG YOU CAN
HOLD THEM IS GOING TO COME UP.
>> WELL, ABSOLUTELY.
I THINK THE NUMBERS ACROSS THE
BORDER WHETHER IT’S SINGLE
ADULTS, FAMILIES OR UACs ARE UP
ACROSS THE BOARD.
UACs ARE TROUBLING.
YOU CAN’T RELEASE THEM LIKE YOU
CAN WITH FAMILY UNITES AND
SINGLE ADULTS THAT THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION IS DOING.
YOU HAVE TO HOLD THEM IN BORDER
PATROL FACILITIES AND HHS
FACILITIES.
WHAT HAPPENS WHEN YOU HAVE SO
MANY IS IT STARTS TO BACK UP
AND I THINK THAT’S WHAT WE’RE
SEEING NOW.
YOU ARE SEEING KIDS HELD FOR
LONGER THAN 72 HOURS, THE TOP
LIMIT OF HOW LONG THEY SHOULD
BE HELD IN BORDER PATROL
FACILITIES.
WHICH ARE ESSENTIAL JAIL-LIKE
SETTINGS.
YOU NEED TO GET THEM TO HHS SO
THEY HAVE A MORE APPROPRIATE
SETTING.
THE END OF THE DAY YOU NEED TO
SEND THE RIGHT MESSAGE.
THE WRONG MESSAGE IS BEING SENT
TO TRAFFICKERS AND SMUGGLERS
AND OTHERS THAT NOW IS NOT THE
TIME TO COME.
THERE IS A TIME TO COME, IT IS
JUST NOT NOW.
THAT MESSAGE IS TOO NUANCED.
THEY WON’T GET IT AND YOU ARE
SEEING THE NUMBERS INCREASE
ACROSS THE BOARD.
>> Bill: DANA MENTIONED SOME
ARE WEARING T-SHIRTS.
THAT’S AN EXTRAORDINARY THING,
IS IT NOT?
THEY’RE WEARING T-SHIRTS LET US
IN.
HAVE YOU SEEN THAT BEFORE?
>> I HAVE NOT.
I THINK WHAT IT TELLS YOU IS
THAT THE ADVOCACY COMMUNITY,
NGOs AND OTHERS THEIR ENTIRE
GOAL IS TO MAKE SURE THAT
ANYONE THAT SHOWS UP AT THE
BORDER GETS INTO THE UNITED
STATES AND ABLE TO STAY PERHAPS
FOR YEARS AND YEARS REGARDLESS
OF WHETHER THEY ACTUALLY HAVE A
LEGITIMATE ASYLUM CLAIM OR NOT.
AND I’M SURE THAT THESE TYPES
OF ORGANIZATIONS ARE PROVIDING
THESE T-SHIRTS TO THESE FOLKS
TRYING TO SEND A POLITICAL
MESSAGE AND TRYING TO PLAY
POLITICS WITH THE SAFETY AND
SECURITY OF THAT BORDER.
>> Dana: I’M REALLY INTERESTED
IN THE CARTEL ANGLE AND WHAT WE
DO THERE.
THERE IS A SHERIFF IN ARIZONA
IN ONE OF THE COUNTIES SAYING
WE JUST BUILT ROADS FOR THE
CARTELS.
THINK ABOUT THAT.
>> YEAH, ABSOLUTELY.
I KNOW SHERIFF DANIELS PRETTY
WELL AND A LOT OF THE LAW
ENFORCEMENT COMMUNITY ALONG
THAT BORDER ARE SEEING
FIRSTHAND THE RESULTS OF WHAT
WE HAVE SEEN OVER THE PAST FOUR
OR FIVE WEEKS.
THEY WILL BE THE ONES THAT WILL
HAVE TO DEAL WITH THE INCREASE
IN ILLEGAL APPREHENSIONS,
PUBLIC SAFETY RISK AND
EVERYTHING ELSE THAT GOES ON IN
THOSE COMMUNITIES.
WHEN BORDER PATROL IS OVERWEMD
STATE AND LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT
NEED TO STEP UP.
NOT ONE INDIVIDUAL SMUGGLED
ACROSS THAT BORDER ILLEGALLY
THAT IS NOT PAYING A CARTEL, A
TRAFFICKER OR SMUGGLER TO DO
THAT.
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION IS
FUELING MORE AND MORE CARTELS
MAKING THEM MORE PROFITABLE
BECAUSE EACH AND EVERY PERSON
THAT THEY SEND ACROSS THE
BORDER IS MONEY IN THEIR
POCKETS.
>> Bill: THAT’S AN
EXTRAORDINARY THING TO SAY.
THE ADMINISTRATION WON’T CALL
IT A CRISIS YET.
MAYBE THAT CHANGES.
WHAT WOULD YOU CALL IT?
>> IT’S ABSOLUTELY A CRISIS.
WHEN YOU START BUILDING TENT
FACILITIES, HHS AND DHS IS
REDEPLOYING OFFICERS FROM THE
NORTHERN BORDER TO THE SOUTHERN
BORDER, YOU HAVE COMMENTS ABOUT
THEY ARE WORKING 24/7.
ALL INDICATIONS ARE IT’S A
CRISIS.
THEY NEED TO BE HONEST WITH THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
THERE IS AN INFLUX OF
INDIVIDUALS THAT WILL LIKELY BE
HISTORIC PROPORTIONS IN THE